[Music]
welcome to earbiscus the podcast where
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time I'm Rhett and I'm linked
this week at the round table of dim
lighting it's that time of year again
man
um
around this time of year we'd like to
give a spiritual update
to each other and to you
good ear biscateer
um how many years ago was it that we
broke open the can of spiritual worms
three years ago three years ago three
years in 2020 before the world changed
we uh came out of the closet the
spiritual closet and told our story of
who we used to be
our background as Evangelical Christians
and why that was no longer who we are
and how we describe ours it's who we
were at the time and of course
the journey came who we were at the time
yeah at the time that we three years ago
but we weren't Evangelical Christians at
the time I know I said and we talked
about who we were yes exactly which was
no longer
Christians even especially of the
Evangelical
American White Church variety
so but my point is yeah it's been
it's been three years since every year
we give a little update you know we just
we we protect a little bit of time for
each of us to have our own episode where
we can
um
just talk about whatever we want to talk
about when it comes to like our
spiritual Journeys because
it's a journey things keep things keep
changing do you think it becomes less
interesting every year I have no clue I
don't think so I'm very interested in
what you have to say today
um
I think that today's your day man um
this one might be interesting not not
because what I'm going to say is
interesting but because the
um I am going to say some things that
I'm kind of like questioned if I should
be as as uh
honest about some of the things that I'm
thinking because because I'm afraid to
lose credibility with people
okay but I'm just like okay credibility
with people oh I'm just I'm just gonna
go for it all right well I'm not gonna
judge you
um
so kind of the way that I process this
you know when we prepare for this
episode is I kind of look back through
the year and I you know I don't do super
regular like daily uh journaling but I
do when there's something significant
that happens or a thought that strikes
me that I'm like I kind of want to
remember that especially as it relates
to spiritual things in this process of
the way I'm thinking about
deconstruction and the way I think about
faith
I have a little folder in my Evernote
the faith folder okay uh where I kind of
catalog these these things just I'm
going to kind of keep track because I am
sort of changing and and
continuing on the journey
and then usually because we do this in
February around Christmas
over Christmas break
I start
looking at this stuff and just kind of
seeing well what patterns formed and
what things happened and
there's a bit of a narrative that I
think unfolded well uh then I'm gonna
try to lead you through right and
awesome
um
I'm just gonna I could get a little
tedious it could get a little tedious
because I'm trying to connect
the the dots that have been connected in
my brain
um and also trying to be honest about
like where like where things are going
and again
I try I try to qualify things when I
when when we talk about these things as
I'm just kind of throwing out some like
giving you as a person as a human as
another human just a data point from
another human who is trying to figure
out what they think about
the nature of the world right not in a
I'm trying to change your mind I'm
trying to persuade you because as you'll
see at the end I don't know exactly what
I'm persuaded of personally it's just
kind of like
as if we were friends sitting around a
campfire and we were like what are you
thinking about spiritual things these
days I would lightly toss some things
out to the group for consideration so
consider it in that way okay into the
fire that would just burn if you don't
like it just throw it directly in the
fire just don't throw me into the fire
who is that
um
is there symbolism in that
talking about hell oh
so you ready
I'm ready man
um I'll give you I'll give you a quick
preview
even though I am
definitely still not a Christian I'm
realizing that I am a person of faith
and I'm figuring out what that Faith
looks like
okay
that's the preview that's that's where
I'm gonna land
just so you know
all right now I know okay you want to
promote something first before I get
into that uh yeah let's let's let's do
any anything because once I get going it
might be hard to stop
there's so many different ways you can
uh enjoy your biscuits
you know you're enjoying it in one way
right now
it could be as a podcast maybe you're
watching us right now
as a YouTube video
yeah uh that's cool that's a cool thing
um you're open to you're open to any of
those ways we want to give you options
uh audio comes out on Monday wherever
you get your podcast and then what used
to come out on Sunday on YouTube now
comes out on Wednesday so just two days
later
we upload the the video version of this
to the earbiscus YouTube channel
subscribe to that
um you can you can share if there's a
part of it that's particularly poignant
to you there's a way that YouTube will
let you share this specific moment like
the time code
but it doesn't stop there
your biscuits is also on Snapchat yeah
it is it's on Snapchat like many sods so
like three to six minute
I'll I'll call them self-contained ish
um segments of the show that if if
you're over there on Snapchat look up
your biscuits add that to your
repertoire and it'll come across your
your feed uh if you're over on Tick Tock
follow mythical pods smaller little
moments from ear biscuits how small can
the moments get
um let's just keep going I would say 15
15 seconds let's see if we can get Vine
to come back
and we'll just put six seconds on there
at a time we post pictures of us talking
to each other on Flickr
that's 124th of a second right
well that lasts forever ever for you it
would last us for as long as you look at
it is there any other place that your
biscuits is showing up that I forgot
about
Twitter Twitter
that's right please hashtag your ear
biscuits there what is the world come
into and of course
no matter what we talk about we want you
to call in and give us your verbal
reaction to it 1-88
earpod one I just promoted every every
place in your business it's pretty
impressive and hopefully it's in your
hearts pretty impressive
okay
you may recall if you have been
following along uh on these these
episodes last year I bought a Bible yes
I remember that you bought a study Bible
and that was your new thing and if
you're hoping that this year is an
update on all the insights I gathered
from all the Bible that I read
you will be sorely disappointed because
I didn't get very far
uh I don't want to trash the Bible and
say that it's boring
um
foreign
but it's kind of boring especially when
you've read it uh like you spent a lot
of your your your time and your previous
life reading it and when you start from
the beginning especially you know that's
why that's why when you do like Bible in
a year there's a reading plan that
doesn't just have you start from the
beginning and try to get through the
Torah because it's so difficult to do
you were so excited about it uh well
it's a moment in time it turns out that
it was an it was a very important moment
in time and it did something
um you know the the
the logic behind getting the Bible you
know the analogy I used last year was if
you were raised in a religion where the
Lord of the Rings was the text and then
you left that particular religion
and but it had to find who you were in
many ways and not just who you were but
who you are now because who you were is
the largest determined you know it is
the largest determiner of who you are
now
and so
it would be like going back and reading
about Frodo Anew Bilbo Gandalf
and basically
seeing like how did these things that I
read and how I interpreted them how did
they make me who I am and how do I see
them now when I go back and look at them
in a fresh Light
but the Bible is not the Lord of the
Rings link
um it was not written For Your
Entertainment
and so uh but what happened before I
realized I was getting kind of I was
slowly trudging through this is that
what it did do is it kind of thrust me
back into
thinking about some of the issues that
were the things that I was thinking
about when my deconstruction was
beginning okay things that I hadn't
really thought about or Revisited in a
while because
my deconstruction in particular
started it's kind of started the
beginning of the Bible you know a lot of
people have an experience in the church
or they or they learn something that
might impact their understanding of
Jesus and then it kind of works
backwards for me it happened with my
changing of understanding of the
beginning of the Bible and the nature of
the Old Testament which then kind of was
the thread that I began to pull that
eventually the whole thing fell apart
so going back to
read those things kind of thrust me back
into
the latest in Christian apologetics
oh which is you know again apologetics
is essentially the defense of the faith
um and there's a whole apologetics
industry
and it has changed quite a bit since I
last checked in and since I was a
student of these resources right because
there's just the the content is so much
more prolific and they're just you're
saying you were reading Genesis in the
Bible and then you started reading what
what the commentary on that now right
but it quickly just became commentary
about all of Christianity and like what
what's the latest in the the arguments
that are happening about different
aspects of the faith on the internet
between you know Christians and atheists
and Progressive Christians etc etc and I
was just kind of Blown Away not
surprising is the blog still happening
mostly in the blogosphere no because it
move to Reddit I mean like you know or
Twitter like where where it's everywhere
but the place that it is the most the
most accessible is YouTube okay because
essentially you've got personality who
have set themselves up as this is my
position this is where I stand and they
interact with each other you know across
disciplines and across perspectives and
it's fascinating to me I love kind of
like watching it unfold because I feel
like there's a little bit of me in every
single argument that I see right because
you know I was a very I was a
professional Christian I was an
Evangelical Christian when I
deconstructed I kind of went through
what I would call a mildly angry atheist
phase which is common to many people who
deconstruct and then I kind of backed
off of that and kind of went into an
agnostic place and I'm continuing to
evolve but you've got all these people
that represent these different
perspectives and I just like seeing them
interact and also having people publicly
sort of change their minds is an
interesting thing that I've seen happen
too
you know which is something that
happened to me I like to hear that
um
but
as I kind of centered around one
particular issue and reading about that
um
some things started to
um solidify to become distilled I don't
know how I would describe it about faith
and reason
that have helped me kind of look
inwardly and kind of figure out why I
think the way I think or help me
organize some of my
thoughts which again will get to what
faith is at this point and how I'm how
I'm leaning into that
and that of the event that there's so
much discussion about of course is the
Resurrection the physical resurrection
of Jesus right because I mean this is
the central
event of Christianity this is the thing
that Paul says that if it didn't happen
if Christ is not raised then you know
your faith is is useless and you know
we're to be pitied above all people
and of course if it did happen then
there's something to this Christianity
thing so it's it makes a lot of sense
that people spend a lot of time talking
about this and a lot of apologists spend
a lot of time defending it and trying to
make a case for why it's reasonable to
believe that Jesus actually raised from
the dead
so in kind of looking at their arguments
well let me just newsflash I'm I'm still
not convinced that Jesus rose from the
dead
um uh you know that's not what this is
about I'm not going to go into why I do
or why I don't believe it but I'm not
about to I'm not about to say that I've
come to the conclusion that Jesus rose
from the dead it's I was very much
um
sort of confirmed in my suspicion
from 10 years ago that I I don't believe
that he didn't I don't believe there's a
good case that he did okay but
one of the things that I've observed is
that if you really want to follow the
argument like if you want to actually
consider the argument for or against the
resurrection there's a few things that
you have to have at least some working
knowledge of right like you got to have
a little knowledge or a little POV on
the historical reliability of the
gospels you got to understand what extra
biblical evidence there is you've got to
understand a little bit about the
history of first century Judaism you got
to understand first century Roman Empire
and how The Empire was interacting with
the Jewish people and and and how their
laws were interacting and and methods of
execution and methods of burial the
early stages of the Christian church and
how it grew and the testimonies of the
the disciples and all this stuff right
and that's a lot it kind of hit me that
most people
and also most Christians including me
when I was a Christian
didn't have a working knowledge of these
things right there may be like oh my
pastor talked about it one Sunday or I
checked in with it with a YouTube video
or a Blog it was more common back in the
day
we're somebody who took the time to
research all this stuff somebody who is
a historian somebody who does you know
who can read Greek or whatever
they have have synthesized this
information for me in a simple to
understand blog post that makes me feel
confident that I'm a Christian who
believes in the resurrection right but
we really I wasn't ever really following
the argument and I'm not even saying
that even now I'm really following the
argument to the degree that a lot of
these people these Talking Heads Are
um
but yet despite the fact that most
Christians don't really follow the full
argument for the Resurrection the
evidence for the resurrection
um most of them if not all well most
Christians believe in the physical
resurrection of Jesus they believe that
it happened sure and and it kind of hit
me I was like but why okay why is that
well because they have faith they have
faith that Jesus rose from the dead
right
because typically the way that the way
that it worked for me is
raised in a Christian household
you know in a Christian Community I make
a decision to become a Christian
at a very young age when I don't have a
real understanding of much and then as
you grow you begin to
build the case for your own faith and
then maybe there is a point that you
have a crisis of faith and you do some
research in a particular area but it's
just to kind of confirm the faith
decision that you already made
so
this and even if you're even if you're
like you are the most informed Christian
on the face of the planet and you're the
guy that writes the book about the
resurrection
the best that you can do
and I don't even believe that this is
possible but let's just for the for the
sake of the argument I'll be generous
and say the best that you can do is make
a case for why it is reasonable to
believe or even probable
that Jesus rose from the dead right I
don't believe that you can but I'm just
saying if you make the case that it's
probable that Jesus rose from the dead
that it is the best explanation for why
the early church got started and it is
the best explanation for the available
evidence
at some point you still have to close
the gap between probability and
certainty with faith
yeah so there's not
proof 100 you can't prove it so at some
point you have to take a leap of faith
and that really got me thinking about
this concept of Faith because I think
there's a tendency for people like me
who've not only deconstructed but
deconverted to just
kind of just believe that you no longer
have faith that there's nothing that I
think that is a leap
to something that I only operate under
reason and logic right you tend to start
believing that but the thing that I'm
realizing is that well I'm Still Human
and I believe that faith
is a feature of humanity for most for
you know for most people
but what is it and so the biblical
definition actually in Hebrews 11 1 I
think is pretty good
the Assurance so faith is the Assurance
of things hoped for the conviction of
Things Not Seen that's the ESV the NIV
says now Faith is the confidence in what
we hope for and Assurance about what we
do not see and then if you're a King
James King James person uh faith is the
substance of things hoped for the
evidence of Things Not Seen
and I think this is like in popular
culture this is kind of how we
understand faith we don't we don't
really talk about it that much but I
actually think it's a great way of
describing the way that Faith operates
in the world
so my sort of the ret McLaughlin version
of this is Faith is a bridge we can use
to travel from the limits of reason to a
confident conclusion of what we hope to
be true
faith is a bridge we can use to travel
from the limits of reason to a confident
conclusion of what we hope to be true so
if you're a Christian who is well
studied in all the evidence for the
resurrection
you still got to get to the point where
you kind of want to you gotta want to
believe that Jesus rose from the dead to
make that final leap to it it's got to
be this thing that you want to be true
and then you believe it to be true but
the desire for it to be true precedes
the belief for it to be true
and again I'm not saying about singling
out Christians because again I'm going
to get to the fact that I think this
applies to most people and it definitely
applies to me and I'm going to talk
about how I see that manifesting itself
in me hmm yeah it seemed
seems like someone may say
yeah but you can you can become
convinced of something like you can be
you can make an argument
you may not want to believe that
Seinfeld is the best
television show of all time but if you
if you listen to enough arguments
you might become convinced of it even if
you didn't want it to be better than
friends or whatever your problem is
um yeah but that's an opinion about a
show that requires taste I'm really just
saying that it seems like well can I be
convinced of something that I didn't
want to be true but then I changed my
mind and then I
it's not really what I like
so I'm just kind of I'm just kind of
pointing out that a lot of people would
think that I think that about some
things yeah but I think you're talking
about a preference so I also think when
it comes to belief of something where
there's not 100 Proof
I I do
believe that like people believe what
they want to believe like it's um at the
deepest level what maybe it's something
that you're agreeing I am agreeing with
you but yeah I was kind of
exploring the other side of it well I
think a good way to figure out like what
part of Faith you know what part of is
the bridge is to think about what reason
is
so the reason is to think understand
informed judgments by a process of logic
so when people are using now first of
all humans are really bad including me
real really bad at
being able to parse between where we're
using reason and where we're using
Intuition or where we're getting into
matters of faith
but one of the beautiful things about
science is that science starts with a
recognition that people
are imperfect especially individual
people and individual communities are
imperfect and prone to
value their own intuition too highly and
also be led by their own bias and so
good science is about isolating the bias
and trying to use as pure reason as
possible as pure logic as possible to
come to conclusions that we can be
confident in things that we can prove
that's why you know if you're studying
some chemistry some aspect of chemistry
in the United States and in China
well if the conditions are controlled
you're going to come to the same
conclusions but if you're studying
theology
you don't have to be in China you can be
across the street the Presbyterians and
the Baptists are across the street from
each other they're studying theology
they're coming to vastly different
conclusions about you know some
fundamental things
and that's because matters of theology
get into matters of Faith which gets
into matters of preference it gets it
gets into things that you want to be
true and not it moves Beyond things that
you can prove to be true this is a
little bit of an oversimplification but
it's one of the reasons that we have we
don't have
um
I mean yes the past three years May uh
challenge this particular view but we
actually do have one set of facts there
is a set of scientific facts that exist
whether or not you're in the group that
has them or you're you subscribe to them
I think we all kind of agree that there
is a truth out there that is that
corresponds to a scientific reality
getting to the bottom of that has gotten
more difficult with polarization Etc but
the incredible diversity of faiths
Christian faiths alone
Christian denominations alone but then
add religions
it's a testimony to the fact that people
are coming to conclusions based on the
things that they want to be true based
on these this Faith decision that sends
people in so many different directions
it doesn't keep bringing people back to
the same conclusions it keeps splitting
people up and moving people away from
each other when it comes to these Faith
issues right I mean we've personally
experienced that with growing up in a
church that there was a difference of an
opinion that led to the formation of a
new church yeah right
um
but the question that hit me or an idea
was what is it that
determines what you want to be true what
is it that if everybody kinda wants
different things to be true as is
evidenced by all these different Faith
perspectives
what is it that determines what someone
wants to be true
and I'm convinced that in large part it
is a combination of circumstance and
disposition
okay and this is why
for the you know even today but
definitely for most of History you just
believed what your parents believed and
what your community believed and what
the people in your culture believed
that's why religions are centered
regionally right because people are
being influenced by a combination of
circumstance and disposition which tends
to run
in patterns regionally in groups of
people
um
and I don't think that there's I I don't
think that this is uh I don't think this
is a bad thing I just think that it's
something to understand about like it's
something that I'm understanding about
myself
because
especially as it relates to Christianity
and my deconstruction so
there could be one view that I could
take of myself which is
um oh I was so brave
in in being in this environment where
everybody believed this same thing and I
decided to challenge it and follow the
truth wherever it would lead and then to
break out of this community because
because I had the courage to do it the
courage of my convictions to follow this
and I'm some enlightened person who who
stepped out of this this type of belief
I do not believe that that's what
happened in any in any sense of the of
those words because I believe that I
came to where I'm at right now
based on a combination of my
circumstances and my particular
disposition and how those things
interact with one another right yeah
um and so and I also think this
has it has a lot to do with how
individual Christians respond to what's
happening in the church when it comes to
deconstruction in general right so the
church's
registering that
some shit's going down right lots of
books are being written lots of videos
are being made
recognizing that
a lot of people are reevaluating on a
fundamental level there this the faith
that they were raised with
and there's a few different ways that
you could you could respond to that many
Christians see it happening and
immediately put those people in a box
and say
those people are deceived
those people are falling to the
temptation of the world and worldly
thinking and placing themselves above
God and they basically just sort of
dismiss those people and be like well
we'll pray for those people but they're
lost right that's a good amount of
Christians would think that
I know some of those Christians I also
know many Christians who take it very
very seriously and actually move Beyond
just thinking about how it affects other
people but have let some of the
information has come out and some
people's stories and perspectives that
have been put out there and they let it
challenge their own faith and they
actually do have some form of
deconstruction of their own faith they
go back they reevaluate why they believe
what they believe they reevaluate like
what parts of this are are true and many
of them
become a different kind of Christian but
at the end of the day still will call
themselves a Christian still have faith
and Jesus still believe in the
resurrection whatever right yeah
and then there are people like me and
you who
threw the baby out with a bath water so
to speak and it was completely left it
behind
and again I think that
most of that
has to do with circumstance and
disposition of these individual people
and how they're interacting with this
so I'm not going to get into talking
about because it may be you may be
saying are you saying you don't believe
in free will like from a deterministic
standpoint you just think that it's just
a combination of environment and DNA and
people just are going to do what they
want to so nobody has any culpability
for anything I'm not saying that
what what I'm saying is that I recognize
in myself and a lot of other people that
they're kind of just they've got the
faculties that they have and they've got
the disposition that they have and new
information comes in and then they react
to it to the best of their ability and
we come to different conclusions and I
think what that has done for me is that
it's helped me withhold judgment from
people okay it's it's what else are you
going to do it's created a s uh a
softness
towards others and towards myself and
when I say softness towards myself
I say it makes me even more suspicious
than I ever was about anything that I
actually believe because I recognize
that it's not like I have some really
really tied up very very reasonable very
very logical package of beliefs that I
have assembled with great care and
without outside influence no I've had
lots of outside influence and I've had
lots of outside influence interacting
with the way that my brain works
and that's why I think the things that I
think
so when I'm able to see myself in that
way I can step back and be like all
right well
can I
uh you I you hold things a little bit
more Loosely yeah you hold your
convictions about other people a little
bit more Loosely and you hold your
personal convictions a little bit more
Loosely because you recognize just how
tenuous the whole Enterprise is
yeah how much influence things you have
no control over
how much influence it has over you yep
right
so and and one thing it makes me
much less uh it makes me want to be much
less dogmatic
in any conclusion that I come to
right
um
but
what does this have to do with
the question of of my faith so
again going back to the
the Assurance of things hoped for
essentially certainty of things that you
want to be true
there's two parts of that
um there's the thing that you want to be
true and then there's the certainty of
that thing and I and I was thinking a
lot about this analogy that I've used
before of me jumping ship you know it's
the analogy that I captured on the the
front of the the cover of the album
me like being in the ocean of
uncertainty and you see the ship of
belief which is like characterized like
Noah's Ark in the in the background oh
um and you took your shoes off for some
reason
because feet you know people want to see
feet
some people more than others well if
you're gonna jump in the water you need
to take your shoes off everybody knows
that just keep your pants on yeah
because what kind of shoes would you be
wearing on your album cover exactly yeah
um
so you I think there's more to this
analogy that has been helpful in
thinking about this aspect of Faith
because the way I characterized it
before is that I was on this ship of
belief and at some point
I decided to jump off of the ship of
belief into the sea of uncertainty
but I wasn't just on this ship
just walking around on this ship
I was actually Tethered to this ship
by many many different tethers oh yeah
and so I I think this for me this is the
way that it that it worked and that is
at some point at a very young age I made
the decision to become a Christian so I
you know I was essentially kind of born
onto the ship of belief right yeah did
make a personal decision a few you know
rededication when you're not sure about
your salvation all that multiple times I
like really re-fast into myself to the
you know put another clip in and
re-fasten myself to the ship but I also
did things like
you know join the youth group and then
went on a mission trip and then started
a Christian band with you and then got
involved with campus Crusade for Christ
and then started leading a Bible study
and then went on a couple December
projects and then went on staff full
time and then married a Christian woman
and then started raising a Christian
family
led a Bible study at that church you do
all these things and every single time
you do that thing to kind of throw
yourself into the belief structure you
add another tether and you look around
and you basically got this web that
you've tied yourself to this belief with
and it's very secure and it's very
certain it's almost second nature yeah
for me
stuff started coming along and
tearing at the ship a little bit and
with it a tether would go right
and over and over time
it got to this place where all my
connections to the thing that I wanted
to be true
fell away and I just found myself
standing on this ship of belief and
being able to see it laid bare and to
really look at it and be like
do you want this to be true you know I
talked about that in my first
deconstruction account
was that once the confidence and the
belief went away
an examination of whether I wanted it to
be true and again this is the kind of
thing I can hear the old Evangelical on
my shoulder being like ha so it was
about what you wanted to be true I knew
it all along
he can say it he can say that if he
wants to but I'm saying that I believe
that everyone is following what they
want to be true and the point at which
you decide to jump ship to either
another Faith or to no faith at all is
because you finally made a decision that
there was another reality that you
wanted to be true
more than the one that you're currently
tied to and at that point I jumped into
the sea of uncertainty
and I've been in that sea of uncertainty
for uh you know basically a decade
but the thing that's been hitting me
this year as I kind of look through my
notes and experience and experiences
specifically which I'm going to get to
some
what I might call Faith building
experiences
I have recognized that I'm not just
floating in the sea of uncertainty I
actually look down and see
tethers to other things that I want to
be true
okay and I am in the process of grabbing
onto that rope and pulling myself
towards whatever ship or island or
whatever it is that's at the end of that
tether of belief
um so are you going to tell us the
tethers yes I'm going to so
I've gotta I've got to order that I'm
gonna kind of unfold this
but I've been having these conclusions
about what is it that I want to be true
what is it that my faith is
and
then I saw it articulated really really
well by none other than Rick Rubin in
his latest book which I'm going to read
an excerpt from
I love that you read this book before me
um you know I a lot of people have been
talking about this book
um there's a few clips of of Rick going
around some viral Clips because he he's
like being interviewed by Anderson
Cooper and he seems to be saying
absolutely nothing and people are kind
of making fun of it and people are
talking about oh how he's you know he
doesn't have any Talent or whatever
because he himself said he doesn't have
any talent I don't care who you are uh
for me personally this book was a
masterpiece like I really think that as
a creative thinker this was because it's
not so much about my it has nothing to
do with my respect for his work or my
knowledge of his work I know a little
bit about what Rick Rubin has done as a
producer and the people that he's worked
with and the albums that have kind of
come out of that process but to me it's
more somebody who understands
a creative way of being a creative way
of living
actually the creative act a way of being
is the is the name of the the book
and I listened to about five hours of
this again I do have the physical book
which I am now reading following up the
the listening
um
but it is uh the first pass of this book
I basically took in in one hike
one hike up a mountain in which five
hour hike in which I uh thought that I
might have to call someone for help
because my knee started hurting so bad
because I have tendonitis
I thought I was gonna have to get air
lifted off of this mountain but I made
it and it was quite an experience let me
let me let me if you want to read it
right now because I do have something
I'm sorry I just saw something I have to
read the very first thing nothing in
this book is known to be true
it's a reflection on what I've noticed
not facts so much as thoughts yeah oh I
feel that so and I actually think that
that is a uh I could have said that at
the beginning of this whole
thing that I'm doing right now
um
because I wholeheartedly believe that
the things that I'm going to tell you
are not things that I can prove or
things that you should even believe
again it's a data point to take into
consideration
but early on in the book he says
something that I was like oh man this is
like one of the things I've noticed in
the past few years is that
and I think this has been the case
always but I've just kind of as I've
detached from a framework of faith
um it's been a little bit easier to
notice when I begin to see some
synchronicities happening in my life and
again I think that we're pattern forming
individuals and that is natural for us
to see things and to begin to put these
patterns together whether or not they're
there or not and I think that noticing
these patterns
can be helpful
whether or not there's some other Force
involved or not but
again I'm having these thoughts about
faith asking myself what is it that I
believe
that I can't prove to be true and how
does I interact with my life and then
and again we've already said that it is
the the evidence of things not seeing
the Assurance of things hope for the
evidence of things unseen and here we
are very early in the book just on page
31 he has a short chapter called the
Unseen
Chatters are short this one in
particular
two pages
I'm going to just read some stuff I
highlighted The Act of Creation is an
attempt to enter a mysterious realm a
longing to transcend
what we create allows us to share
glimpses of an inner landscape one that
is beyond our understanding art is our
portal to the Unseen World
without the spiritual component the
artist works with a crucial disadvantage
the spiritual World provides a sense of
wonder and a degree of open-mindedness
not always found within the confines of
science
the world of Reason can be narrow and
filled with dead ends while a spiritual
Viewpoint is Limitless and invites
fantastic possibilities the Unseen World
is boundless
the practice of spirituality
is a way of looking at a world where
you're not alone there are deeper
meanings behind the surface the energy
around you can be harnessed to elevate
your work you are part of something much
larger than can be explained a world of
immense possibilities harnessing this
energy can be marvelously useful in your
creative Pursuits the principle operates
on faith believing and behaving as if
it's true no proof is needed no
so I'm hiking up the mountain
I'm listening to this and I'm like
this is
this is kind of remarkable and Light
of a couple of things that have happened
to me over the past year
okay
um
so
I read and I think I talked about this
um
last year or the year before I read
Elizabeth Gilbert's book big magic which
is a great book on creativity
and she describes the creative process
in a very magical way
and again anytime somebody starts
talking about magic I get my all my
alarms go off I'm a skeptic all the red
flags go up I'm like you've got no way
of proving this I'm not going to believe
it
she tells a story in the book about how
she had a very specific idea for a book
very specific it was a character it was
an occupation it was a location it was a
plot
and she abandoned the idea only to have
it
um
essentially
done by someone else with all the same
specifics being hit and she ended up
meeting this woman and there's a story
about it in the book but it's based on
the idea that
these ideas these Concepts exist outside
of us they are in the fabric of the
universe in the fabric of this existence
and we have the ability to tap into them
not a new idea
obviously it's at least as old as the
Greek Muses you know in ancient Greece
where they believed that there were
these gods and goddesses who had
basically the power to inspire all forms
of Art in in and Science and everything
right there are these Timeless truths
and Melodies and
Arrangements of ideas that existed that
you can kind of tap into if you're a
creative person now this sounds like
serious La woo-woo New Age [__] that I'm
not into right
um but it is an interesting way to think
about creativity and it's an interesting
way to think about ideas and so I think
the way I interacted with that book when
I saw it was when I read it was
okay yeah there's probably another
explanation for this like hey I don't
know exactly what it is but I feel like
I'm hearing one half of this and there's
probably a logical reasonable
explanation for how this actually went
down
but it's cool to think about it in this
way and it's inspirational and maybe it
will unlock something in the creative
process and as a creative person as a
creative professional this is an
inspiring way to think about creativity
well
last year
in the fall
um
no it's over it's over a year ago so
fall 21.
I was on and I'm not gonna and I'm not
going to say what these specific ideas
are because in doing that I run the risk
of
trying to take credit for the ideas and
I'm not going to do that and so I don't
want you to be thinking about specific
ideas I just want you to be listening to
my testimony of how these things went
down for me okay
um the first thing that happened was I
was on vacation and I had I was in the
middle of a conversation with Jesse and
my brother and sister-in-law and I had
an idea for a for a series it was a very
specific
series
um
and I kind of just wrote it down
and then we come back to to work come
back to mythical and a team here at
mythical has
developed the idea
and developed the idea
in a much more specific better way than
I had just sort of like initially
sketched it out I never told anybody
about it right
I was like that's weird but again I was
like
foreign
the coincidences happen we all work in
the same place like we probably talked
about this it probably just came up and
it's just like now I'm seeing it now
there's this pattern yeah
well
about
three weeks ago
yeah
um so I know what you're talking about
so you know we are coming up with ideas
for videos that we're going to make that
we're very excited to show you
uh we'll talk more about what that
process looks like
and
um
we've got a bunch of ideas we're very
excited about and just I'm so excited
and I'll talk about how this all ties
into how excited I am about what we're
doing
but
we're trying to kind of land on
uh an idea
um for like a a video
and
I took a I was actually here in the
office and I took a little power nap and
I woke up and I had an idea for a video
and it was
it was such what I would call a dumb
idea that I was afraid to even admit to
myself that I'd had that it was just
like that's a dumb idea I'll never
mention that to anybody but it's weird
that I had that idea that's all that's
what I remember thinking yeah I was like
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna write it
down I'm not gonna tell link about it
because
it's stupid it's a dumb idea
and then
is it I think it was the same day same
day yeah uh we have a meeting
um
you were at the meeting yeah Jenna was
at the meeting I think as well or were
you not you know maybe you weren't back
you weren't back from your your trip yet
um
but TJ who's leading that this team
he's like I gotta he's like I got a dumb
idea but I love it and he says the idea
and I'm like what
same idea
and of course very specific and also but
again and it was very uh he
I mean we're doing it and we're doing
his idea was he had thought of it and
developed it into like man this is how
we would do it yeah he's got more balls
than you I guess and I'm so appreciative
of it and it's funny because I told him
after the fact I was like
you know everybody left and he kind of
stayed back for a second I was like Hey
I want to let you know because he you
know just started working for us and I
was like
what I did in that meeting May make me
feel made me make me seem like a
completely
psychotic maniacal boss and that I'm
gonna be the kind of boss that when you
have an idea I'm gonna say I just had
that idea when I woke up from a nap a
second ago and I was like I realized I
realized how that and I'm I promise you
I'm not going to do that but I was
literally like floored by the fact that
I had this very specific idea to come to
me in a power nap in another room
and then you come in and we have this
meeting and
he was like trust me I didn't think that
um and so it was again it was just an
additional experience and then
and then I go on the hike and I read the
Rick Rubin book
yeah the very next weekend
and he doesn't just talk about it
explicitly in that chapter the whole
book is essentially about making
yourself the best possible antenna that
you can be because the idea is that
these
these patterns and these ideas exist and
you're tapping into them again this is
some new age [__] right it is yeah and
um
but again it's inspirational when I when
I when I was listening to the book and
now reading through it again it's like
this is this the resonant frequency of
this is is my resonant frequency it's
but then
um and again I'm sorry that I'm going to
be speaking in
um I'm almost speaking like Vegas Road
and vagaries
but
we just had an experience this past
weekend with some creative people
where this principle of someone's
ability to tap into something
that is definitely external
that is outside of them was demonstrated
in a really powerful way
and I was like okay all right all right
Mr skeptic you've kind of why don't you
just why don't you just release your
grip on this a little bit because I'm so
tempted to just try to understand what
it is that's going on and maybe I'm just
I think you can tell I mean just like
the general principle of like
uh you know having
someone getting a sense of
us like it was a new friend we made who
was like a very gifted musician
and was able to translate
um
he can translate their experience of a
person or us into music
improvisationally yeah and it was it was
it was extremely moving very
and also like
very specific in shocking ways
to the individuals who are present
given the type like some of the music
that he played right but also there was
a moment in which
like a an album cover that had been
created
a few years ago for a moment that he had
planned for in a specific month while we
were all looking at a specific thing and
then he played the music and then showed
us the album cover and it was
it was too much for me to handle as as
as Rick Rubin says in another chapter
they're they're become these things that
you that Randomness it doesn't provide
an adequate explanation for these things
and you eventually sort of just
acquiesce
I feel like
um
yeah there's something unseen happening
well so again now this is as someone who
was a person of Faith a person of
Christian faith it's very different to
be thinking about these these things on
this side of it because I am so ready to
admit that there's nothing here
just so you understand
like I'm not trying to tell you that
it's true I don't think that it applies
to you I I don't think that it's
important that you understand it I don't
think I need to convince you to agree
with me I don't think you need to join a
community in which we all believe this I
don't think that this determines where I
go when I die I don't think that I can
prove this to you I don't think that
this is a universal truth that applies
to every single person
those are things that I believe when I
was a Christian
I'm saying there's some [__] going down
that is uh uh really has developed sort
of a synchronicity and a frequency
uh in the way that it's appearing in a
way that is
very much coinciding with where I'm at
right now in my life and one of the
things that you let you know Reuben said
was
it's believing
or behaving as if it's true
the belief the proof is not really the
important thing especially if it's not
harmful because because I think that uh
I do first of all let me just say that I
think it's very important that we agree
with things that are reasonable and
logical and provable you know I would
say that for instance you know Evolution
common ancestry the fact that we're all
related that we all came from the same
organism like I think that's provable I
don't think that that's an opinion I
think that that has been demonstrated
significantly through many different
scientific Avenues and I think it's
important to believe that and I think
that it is harmful to not believe that
and that's going to piss a lot of people
off because like 40 to 50 percent of the
population in the United States doesn't
think that's true but I actually think
it's harmful to to to ultimately not
believe that
that's a that's a podcast for a
different time but I believe that
because I believe it's very reasonable
and logical to come to that conclusion
and it can be demonstrated through lots
of different methods but the stuff that
I'm talking about right now I'm saying
it is it's out on that Faith Bridge it's
out on something that I'm not trying to
prove to you I don't think I can prove
it to you but it is me leaning into some
sort of exercise of faith
and it's a little it's wild because of
the way that it coincides with the way
that me and you have been talking and
some of the things that have happened
with us specifically
um the way that we've been thinking
about our creative
Destiny for lack of a better word
um
and trying to continue to become
more free
in the things that we're creating yeah
and also more soul-driven in the things
that we're creating and not just do what
I feel like we we've got one of the
things we've gotten very good at doing
over the past
decade is
creating a really really healthy
business through creative Pursuits right
we know how to we know how to run a
creative business very very well
um but sometimes
business interests
can be a counterproductive voice to
creative Pursuits
and they can be they can compromise true
Creative Vision and execution
that's a conversation that we've been
having
and trying to free ourselves up to
actually create from the heart in a way
that is
very attuned to what it is that we feel
is we are specifically positioned and
equipped to create
and then you add this aspect and the
fact that this principle has already
occurred even in the process of this new
creative thing with the whole idea and
the two ideas that same idea of being
kind of dispensed at the same time
and I'm trying to reconcile all this I I
don't again I my sort of uh skeptical
reasonable mind is trying to like piece
it together and I think that
uh
you know one of our friends who was
there this weekend as I was talking
about some of this stuff I'm like it's
very challenging to me because I TR I I
try to build a framework that is that I
can explain and I can justify and defend
and I find myself moving into
adopting a framework of creative
thinking and faith
which is a word I don't even like to say
that it applies to me
um
I find myself doing that and I and it's
very uncomfortable
it feels risky right and it feels
indefensible and again it feels uh
incredible like I'm literally losing
credibility
right like whatever with any with
anybody you've got the you've got the
the the conservative Christians who
would be listening who would be saying
oh okay so you still believe some stuff
and now you're telling us that we
believe some stuff and first of all let
me say yes
your religious Faith isn't something
that uh I am
that I am becoming slower to Jo I am
becoming slower to judge people's
religious faith
because
I do believe there are many people who
have a religious framework and it is
very helpful for them
like I said I think there can be harmful
beliefs within that
right I think if you think that
someone's lifestyle
or someone's existence is a sin that's a
harmful belief and I'm going to stand up
against that if you're if your worldview
embodies that kind of thing I'm not I
don't think there's an excuse for that
um but if your world view if the aspects
of your worldview even a Christian
worldview are
um
they contribute they contribute to all
of us and the well-being of all of us
then that's and then I'm not going to
argue with that
but for me just this I'm kind of I'm
rhythmic at this point because this is
this is the point that I've gotten to
where I'm like ah there's some stuff
happening I can't explain it I'm leaning
into it I've never been more excited
about
um
you know my life in our career
creatively
and I did not expect these things to
coincide I always thought that these two
things were separate back in the day the
way I saw creativity and the kingdom of
God was the kingdom of God was something
that existed that that we were
contributing to on Earth
and trying to you know fulfill the Great
Commission and God had given us the gift
of
whatever you want to call the gift that
we have
um the the gift to make people laugh
whatever
he had given us that gift so that we
could use it to grow his kingdom
yeah and I think that
this is challenging that framework
because it feels much more integrated
and ineffable and difficult to wrap your
mind around
uh because it's almost like
the create the Act of Creation
becomes the experience of God
it is a it is there is something where
it is direct
it is a direct
connection that I can't
take translate understand and put into
English
so that I can get a group of people to
understand it it's just something that
is experienced in these fleeting moments
and all I can do is lean into it yeah
and make myself more attuned to it yeah
I have a lot of thoughts about this
like our
our work and
the relationship with belief
so I can I think I'll I'll go back to
all that as it relates to me but I guess
my one question I have
so are you able to say
you're you're able to say that
you have faith
like you recognize that you you have
faith
are you able to say what that's in
yeah yeah so
yeah that was a part that I had written
down I wanted to say and I completely
forgot so thanks for asking
um you're welcome I think
and I don't think this has ever gone
away
so again the way that I interpret faith
is what is it that I want to be true
that I am what are you hoping for living
and believing as if it is true yeah
and even apart from these experiences I
don't think I've ever let go of the
the belief
that
there is something
beyond my understanding
and there is an intention behind our
existence
that's something that I want to be true
in other words I want there to be
a deeper intention and purpose and
meaning behind our Collective existence
and I don't know again
big difference
I don't think I can prove it
and I'm not trying to I'm just saying
for me
I just have to be honest with myself and
admit that I do want that to be the case
I want there to be some magic right and
I want there to be
um
I wouldn't go as far as to say I want
there to be a personal force behind it
all because I feel like that's
too specific and also me trying to like
put a label on it
but
whether you want to call it Source or
God or whatever
um there being some sort of intention
that is
um involved in some way you know I I
talked at one point about is is the
universe like
some creative force that birth literally
birthed itself
as the universe and
all these pieces of matter including me
and you and everybody it's like the
universe playing you know the way that
Alan Watts describes it is the universe
is playing hide and seek with itself
and so being like Oh I'm gonna make
these two guys
best friends and they're gonna have this
parallel path and they're going to
create these things
you know it's it's more fun and more
fulfilling for me personally to believe
that that's there's some aspect of that
that is true
I think that
you're describing
like a connection you're hoping for
there to be
um
meaning and like it an unseen realm that
like
that we can tap into
and you don't know if it's if it's
personal if it's a personal God or
whatever that is but I think you're
describing
and and openness and experiences where
you have received something
do you think that
you want or have you started have you
ever made an intentional
um and like
Salvo like and uh of moving towards that
like
for some people that may be prayer you
know it's like realizing that the act of
creativity
is
is something that you were just doing
that it you seem to be describing that
like you're you you received
a signal like the way that he talks
about in his book of like being that
antenna you didn't you didn't know those
words at the time
but I think you're you're seeing that
that's happened to you you have
experienced that have you turned that
around to be more intentionally what for
some people might be prayer or
um meditation or just like an
acknowledgment
um yeah but I don't think that uh a lot
of it was conscious
so I mean the whole this whole book is
about
is about
uh your life and like
and again Rick rubin's not the only one
to ever talk about this stuff but
basically meditation meditation is a
part of it well he's talking about
acting on something that you hope to be
true
and in a
through creativity
you know it's but that's an exercise of
Faith yes so to me yeah I I what I'm I
guess what I'm saying is that is it
becoming more intentional now that
you're coming to these realizations yes
and how yes curious yeah well okay so
for me I feel like a huge part of this I
mean obviously me and your we we create
for a living and so we're like we've
been in this mindset for a really long
time
but because we kind of create in this
environment
um and it is this business
like I said there are some things that
have maybe caused us to not make as many
Connections in this way
because who's got time for that when
you're running a business
but the process of doing my own music
which was not intended to be a
commercial success I knew that it would
not be going in right and it was
incredibly personal and it was also very
spiritual yeah it opened something yeah
that makes sense it tapped into
something
you know and it's funny because you hear
they're even in this this it happened
this weekend because
there was this moment that Jesse and I
had together this weekend where I said
something to her
and she was like I want to remember
I want to remember what you said it's
just a phrase
and then I said it back to her and then
it hit me I was like
that's a song
so you started singing it to her no but
I was thinking about it in the shower um
on
yesterday morning
and I just like started singing it in
the full Melody of the song first in
chorus came to me well there you go and
I just recorded it into my phone and
then
and then picked it back up at the end of
the day and just finished the song nice
and it was like
I mean that I mean again that can be
just that could that there could be
absolutely nothing
inexplicable unseen Supernatural
involved in that process I completely
acknowledge that
but the framework of kind of leaning
into this idea that like oh here okay
this thing's coming in here it is oh
turn your satellite towards it
and take it in yeah
um because it's happening right now
I find that to be
a very powerful act and I and and I
think I'm okay with it being a spiritual
Act
it's very intriguing to me because you
know my
Christian faith was so defined on what I
was to do
and like my Pursuit
yes it's like oh you know God is
pursuing you you just gotta answer the
call you just gotta open the door but
for me it really came to all right yeah
I've opened the door and now it's like
what are all the things that I need to
do there wasn't a lot of successful
sitting and receiving
and like and there certainly wasn't any
surprise that I recall you know it's and
I think that's quite discouraged for in
our tradition yeah I think you you being
alone and receiving how can that be a
dynamic relationship when you're never
surprised by what you could receive from
the other
from the other and that's not all
Christians I mean there's charismatic
Christians who who a lot of people
receive things or whatever but like in
sort of the reformed circles that we
right it's like you receive things
through the Bible we're very suspicious
of anybody who receives something
you know that what that didn't align
with scripture and so it really stunts
the process and so you just kind of
developed this inability to trust
yourself and you're just like well I'm
just a sinful instrument tainted with
original sin that needs God and that's
my only hope
um it's kind of a catastrophic way to
see yourself
uh you know in many ways so
yeah so to answer your question yeah I
am leaning into it but it's it's more
about
it is kind of it is sort of a trust a
very like
slow moving careful trust and faith
that is rooted in Stillness and
listening
so one of the things that we've been
talking about is
you know we don't operate like your
typical creative professional we uh we
run a business our schedule
traditionally has been very very full
and our creative time has been scheduled
which most creative people would say
this is counterproductive because you
can't schedule these moments in which
the song is going to come to you in the
shower
but we are prioritizing more of a
Stillness and a more of a passive and
receptive
um posture to let these ideas come to
fruition
and we're getting more protective about
that and we're going to continue to get
even more protective about it yeah
um and so to me that's a big that's a
big that's a big part of it and then
we're also having discussions about what
does it mean for us to use our
um
our creativity
not just to create things
for people to enjoy but also like what
you know
what kind of healing can come about from
the creative act yeah you know yep
that's it that's it yes that's a
discussion that is starting and yeah and
even Good Mythical Morning
um we've been talking to the team
about
giving more over to them so that like
the maximum amount of the show can
happen to us I think yeah even if if you
think of it in terms of this
conversation
um
it's like the best thing we can do is
just to be like a just to receive what
comes from the show and it might be you
know it it might be a dumb food
combination or some silly game or
whatever it is it's like
um the more we're actually there for it
and the more that we can I feel like
we're receiving
something that we just we we turn around
and authentically joyfully
um
process it and exude it just just throw
it right back out you know it's not like
we're not we're no longer making this
show that like we've got to give you
something it's like we've we've prepped
this thing that we gotta give it's like
no we're we've created this playground
this environment and this is what we're
focusing on now is trusting people to
create an environment where we can be
and trust that
um
what comes out of that will will bring
the most recent conversation like you
said is healing to people and it's been
happening it's just like understanding
that dynamic
is very exciting even within the context
of being behind that desk because
it's it's like oh we we can we can even
tune it
the whole environment every everything
about it to
um
to
to give that even more what's what what
people have already been receiving for
years and telling us about you know
people describe to us the experience of
that show in a way that like we're still
making sense of right I'll talk more
about that next week in terms of like
what that what that does
to me on a soul level but like I am
I have no clue what's going on but I
know that it's good I know that it's
really good and I think that that's my
you know that's my teaser for me next
week but I just feel like that you know
that's what that's why we're on the same
page we got this there's this resonance
that's like new and we're noticing it oh
yeah
um it's undeniable yeah and it's uh
yeah it's a it
when you're onto something you can feel
it
you know when you're on to something you
can feel it I think we're feeling it
yeah you know so
um and boy that sounds mystical it's
like why we're the ones saying this type
of stuff well we are gone off the deep
end man like I think you know we have
gone off the deep end I think it's just
embracing embracing that fact
um and so my my wreck of course is is uh
Rick rubin's book which again I I think
there's so many good books on creativity
um
and people have been given the internet
people have uh very strong opinions
about Rick Rubin apparently
um but for me as a creative person who
is trying to to tap into more
of the potential that exists
uh some of these principles were just
very
resonant
why don't you keep highlighting stuff
and then let me let me read it after you
I'm just going to read the parts you
highlight okay I'm going to listen to
this whole thing
smart
it's a record see that one oh he it's
not necessarily
oh you think it's a booby oh yep
okay so whatever you want it to be my
this is a boobie and this is a booby
without a nipple
did I ruin it for you
nope it's not something I will let you
do all right I'm looking forward to
hearing from you next week
uh in the meantime join the conversation
hashtag ear biscuits and you know let us
know what you're thinking how are you
experiencing these things are we crazy
call us 1-888 earpod one
hi Rhett and Link this is honey I'm from
Maryland I just listened to your episode
about your biggest fears I know I'm a
little behind but so worth it because I
now have a complete new fear of lizards
detaching their tails so I just wanted
to say thank you because that consumed
my entire night and I can't stop
thinking about it have a great day
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]